In Syria, over 64,000 Syrians are stranded at the border with Jordan...
...after violence intensifies around Aleppo.
In Turkey, Prime Minister Ahmet Davutoglu calls on the ruling AK Party...
...to avoid divisions after announcing he was stepping down.
In Kenya, rescue workers in Nairobi have pulled three more survivors...
...from the ruins of an apartment building that collapsed nearly a week ago.
In the UK, London could get its first Muslim mayor...
...as Sadiq Khan, a 45-year-old former government minister...
...and son of Pakistani immigrants, appears headed for victory.
And finally from the US, the US. Food and Drug Administration...
...announced for the first time that it is banning the sale of e-cigarettes...
...and some other tobacco products to people under the age of 18.